all right so let's follow up about the
aaron rodgers story aaron rodgers is
apologizing
to anyone that felt misled
okay
aaron rodgers is sorry
if he upset
anybody yeah so let's reset um nfl
quarterback aaron rodgers has issued a
pseudo
bogus apology
after getting caught lying about being
quote immunized against covid19
catching covid
and then saying on the pat mcafee show
that he's been listening to joe rogan
for medical advice and is taking
ivermectin so it's like where do we even
start i guess let's kind of lead up to
this
first here is a reminder this is aaron
rodgers the green bay packers
quarterback in the summer this was in
august
asked
have you been vaccinated
and he says i've been immunized which is
a different word and it was a lie it was
a lie any conversation
are you vaccinated what's your stance on
vaccinations yeah i've been immunized
you know there's a lot of uh
a lot of conversation around it around
the league and a lot of guys who
so the fact that this was a very strange
word salad might have been a sign he was
lying have made statements and i made
statements owners who made statements
um
you know those guys on the team that
haven't been vaccinated
uh i think it's a personal decision i'm
not going to judge those guys
those guys have been vaccinated they've
contracted covid
so
it's it's an interesting issue
that i think we're gonna see
he's he's interested in the issue he's
also lying lying lying so fine he lied
about being immunized vaccinated
whatever
he catches covet great
so then uh he's gonna misses last week's
game or a few days ago game
um admits that he was taking and is
taking medical advice from joe rogan
who's a podcaster joe rogan is not a
doctor um and
when he says this we played this clip on
monday pat mcafee can barely contain his
laughter he actually has to cover his
mouth to avoid laughing directly in
aaron rodgers face let's go to that clip
we looked at this on monday i consulted
with a now good friend of mine joe rogan
after he got covered and i've been doing
a lot of the stuff that he recommended
in his podcast right and you know on the
phone to me and
i'm gonna have the best immunity
possible now okay so he made a lot of
dubious claims in that interview where
he said an israeli study says you get
better immunity from just recovering
from covet of course what the israeli
study says is that
it's better not to catch it at all
but that you get actually the best
immunity from recovery plus vaccination
that's the best immunity so literally
what he says is a lie there as well
so then comes the apology and again it's
one of these pseudo apologies um new
york magazine's benjamin hart had a
great phrase he calls it the
quintessential
non-apology apology to anyone that was
upset this is a classic we've seen this
time and time again
if anybody was upset because he lied to
them and put people at risk he's
apologizing if you found yourself upset
by that uh okay let's listen so i just
want to start off this show by
acknowledging that you know i made some
comments that that people might have
felt were misleading and
uh if you felt
his obvious lies were misleading
uh his completely demonstrable lies were
misleading he's sorry that you felt that
way
you know to anybody who felt misled by
those comments i'd take full
responsibility for those comments
and
i'm excited about feeling better i'm
excited about moving forward and
hopefully getting back on my team right
and getting back to doing what i do best
and that's playing ball it's been tough
to be away from it
um i've been you know obviously dealing
with uh
the covid and i feel like i'm uh i'm on
on the other side of it thankfully and
thankful
uh to still be able to uh have some look
forward to this weekend hopefully well i
appreciate you opening with that and
stating that and you talked about the
reflection that you've had here all by
yourself in your covid cave over there
in green right
so it's a very crappy apology but like
why is he even doing it but this is
starting to cost him money now we can't
say for sure that's why he's issuing
this
you know maybe
he could have offered a better apology
but he was dropped by a health care
company that he had been working with
for years um aaron rodgers and previa
health have ended their nine-year
partnership and previa put out a
statement saying previa health remains
deeply committed to protecting its
patients staff providers and communities
amidst the pandemic
this includes encouraging and helping
all eligible populations to become
vaccinated to prevent the virus from
further significantly impacting lives
and livelihoods so previa health making
it clear
we're not going to do any we're not
we're not working with aaron rodgers
anymore
state farm cut most of its commercials
with aaron rodgers from being broadcast
this past weekend now it seems that
they're still continuing the partnership
for now
uh and they put out a statement saying
quote we don't support some of the
statements he has made but we respect
his right to have his personal view we
recognize our customers employees agents
and brand ambassadors come with all
walks from all walks of life with
differing viewpoints on many issues we
encourage vaccinations but respect
everyone's choice to make uh
make decisions based on their personal
circumstances so
that's the latest it seems as though i
mean listen at least the timing is
uh companies that pay aaron rodgers have
partially or fully stepped back or
walked away from those relationships
and he issued this kind of bogus pseudo
apology so what's the takeaway here i
think the takeaway is uh get medical
advice from doctors
don't lie about being immunized or
vaccinated or whatever word you choose
to use
um and don't spread this information i
mean the the takeaways aren't really any
different just because it's aaron
rodgers rather than your crazy uncle
posting to facebook it's really the
exact same takeaways and we're going to
have more on this on our instagram you
can follow the david pakman show on
instagram at davidpakmanshow you can
also follow me on instagram at
david.pacman we're going to take a very
quick break
and i'll be back with much more right
after this
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video